lundi politique gaël le dantec
l'écologie peut-elle se dissoudre dans
la politique traditionnelle ou dans les
nouveaux clivages entre mondialisation
et nationalisme ou est-elle devenue
finalement une doctrine politique à part
entière depuis sa troisième place aux
européennes le candidat d'europe
écologie yannick jadot se présente comme
une alternative prête à prendre le
pouvoir et non plus comme une simple
force d'appui nous demanderons à notre
invité s'il partage cette vision de
l'avenir nous lui demanderons aussi
quelles conséquences cela pourrait avoir
ici à la réunion où le parti écologiste
est arrivée en quatrième position
comment ce parti se prépare-t-il pour
les prochaines échéances
où en est on des dossiers chauds autour
de l'écologie transports en commun
carrière nrl transition écologique et
jean pierre marchau secrétaire régional
d'europe écologie les verts conseiller
municipal de saint denis et président de
la commission transports à la cinor est
avec nous sur la première jusqu'à 13h
vos questions à partir de 12h45 au 0262
99 de mails et jean pierre marchau
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
la mentalité c'est d'abord le bac philo
passé ce matin par par les élèves de
terminale parmi les sujets tombés ce
matin lequel auriez vous choisi vous qui
est on le rappelle un prof de philo à la
retraite je vous en propose deux sujets
à celui qui était un de ceux qui a été
proposé pour la série l
qui est il possible d'échapper au temps
et un autre pour la série es qui est la
morale est elle la meilleure des
politiques plus les politiques les plus
vieux débat c'est vrai qu'on voit là
toute la composition bruit qui se fait
actuellement avec la défection ou
d'éclat n'est qu'en partie se fait sur
cette question là est ce que leur
reproche aux élus sans même me soit -10
gilet jaune c'est le fait d'avoir des
comportements et vous des discours très
éloignés de leur comportement réel donc
le rapport entre ce qu'est la politique
et les tic les c'est vrai que la
politique si elle veut être efficiente
elle doit prendre des décisions
tranchées passer des compromis mais il
ya une limite et de cette limite c'est
la question de l'éthique et c'est
pourquoi les tigres ailleurs où la
morale pour être faire simple est au
coeur du programme d'europe écologie
c'est aussi
sur lesquels nous sommes extrêmement ne
seront posées gens depuis très longtemps
la question par exemple de la parité
hommes femmes etc ou le refus de de
finalement de s'engager avec délice les
gens cumulent des condamnations en tout
ça ça fait partie de notre orientation
politique mais ça devrait être de plus
en plus partagée par vous y croyez vous
encore à la morale en politique
oui oui je pense qu'on peut être enfin
la politique est restée moral bien
entendu vit pas que seul coup je pense
qu'il faut aussi savoir c'est à dire
tous les polissons courbu mon qui suit
l'imitateur jouera beaucoup d'élus aux
coujoux ont été comme sont des gens qui
travaillent qui sont sincères qui peut
se tromper ça arrive à tout le monde
donc je pense que vous évitez mais c'est
vrai que je prends la question du cumul
des mandats c'est certains élus sont des
super cumulard s'est autorisé par la loi
est ce que c'est bien moral quand on a
des cumuls de fonctions les cumuls
banalité et que l'on ait coupé
totalement de la vie du citoyen modeste
qui l'attendent à la réunion ne sais pas
ce que c'est le devis avec le moins de
800 euros par mois
je vois qu'on revient un peu sur le bac
2 2 ce matin la fonction les conditions
dans lesquelles ça s'est passé puisque y
avait des syndicats d'enseignants qui
qui appelait à la grève pour protester
contre contre la la la loi bancaire la
loi pour la confiance dans l'école est
ce que vous soutenez vous cette date qui
vous avez parce qu'on rappelle vous êtes
vous étiez aussi un responsable syndical
oui aujourd'hui mal à critiquer mais mes
collègues ne fera évidemment mais je
rappelle qu'en 2003
les pros du fils au jeu là j'en faisais
partie nous avons lancé la prise de
groupe i s'il y avait eu une grande
gravité de mes trois mois elle avait
refusé on était cinq ou six a refusé de
prendre le conflit donc on a reçu une
lettre recommandée du rectorat qui nous
a mis en demeure de prendre nos copies
donc voilà on a fini par les prendre
mais on voulait parquet on l'espérait au
delà donc quelquefois on est obligé d'en
arriver là donc c'est un peu regrettable
mais je suis moins dans l'actualité
syndicales aujourd'hui mais je soutiens
évidemment mes collègues c'est bon on a
le sentiment pour rester sur cette
question de l'éducation et du ce du
syndicalisme que le gouvernement actuel
les syndicats disent société le le cas
en tout cas de l'invité de flée dernier
qui était chez nous soient sains le
représentant du ce du snes sup fsu qui
disait ça fait des mois des semaines
qu'on demande à être entendu qu'on veut
être entendu sur cette question de la
réforme de l'éducation et le
gouvernement ne nous entend pas ne nous
écoute pas est ce que c'est le sentiment
que vous avez aussi qu'il ya un
difficultés de communication avec le
gouvernement actuel qui pourtant dit que
il est allé coûte que les réformes ont
évolué au fil du temps qui se pose
depuis de très nombreuses années parce
que comme vous le dites j'ai été
longtemps responsable syndical et même
quand j'étais jeune étudiant déjà ou
intéressés par la question éducative je
sais que la nécropole qui était posée
c'est que souvent le gouvernement de
droite ou de gauche d'ailleurs le fond
des réformes des réformes mais sentent
qui est vraie concertation avec les
forces syndicales quel que soit
d'ailleurs est encore long les courants
suite et à préfecture de bras de fer
parce que l'addition qui était prise
n'est pas que tu voies extérieures ou à
des intentions cachées que les forces
syndicales sont là pour détecter et pour
porter à la connaissance du public et
pour éviter que la le déclin de l'école
à vienne re le continuer c'est le grand
problème aujourd'hui de là
questions régionales et jean pierre
marchau les écologistes ont réalisé un
bon score aux élections européennes en
tout cas au niveau national ou 10 au
delà de ce que disent les sondages en
troisième position c'était nul une bonne
surprise pour vous comment est-ce que
vous l'expliquer oui d'autant bonne est
meilleure cette surprise que je ne m'y
attendais pas si je pensais qu'on est
pas loin de 10 % au plan national elle
est très émue % sachant qu'il y a par
rapport à notre meilleur score en 2009
ou à la réunion les faits pincer 14% et
hong nationale française de 17% en 2009
y avait onze listes là il y avait 34 1 3
fois plus de liste donc forcément
mécaniquement il ya moins de votes en
faveur d'une hélice et se répartissent
dans c'est une bonne chose pour nous ça
veut dire que les mauvais moments que
nous avons connus et quelques années
sont derrière nous et que surtout que
l'écologie redevienne une priorité même
si j'en suis bien conscient
il faut appliquer sur états européenne
sur les futures on sait que là les
européennes sont trop favorables aux au
vote écolo on seynois d'attirer le sont
aussi les échecs du passé à voir comment
aujourd'hui bâtir une offre politique
centré qui fasse de l'écologie est
question centrale comment est ce que
vous expliquez que le vôtre score ici à
la réunion est moins bon finalement que
co nationale regarde attentivement les
chiffres et comme j'avais cette année
effectivement outre europe ecologie
avait il s'appelle urgence écologie dans
le but un thé vert comme le nôtre et
puis aussi partie animalistes les deux
ont fait d'immenses pressions
on reprend les trois existait aussi au
niveau national oui je prends la réunion
la presse c'est une addition des 3a les
trois votes
on a volé le chiffre qu'en 2009 20e
c'est fait plus de 28 mai doit sans
doute des gens qui sont sensibles à
l'environnement l'écologie protection
animale donc aimé le fait est qu'à la
réunion c'est un peu on dirait je
détournais déformé par le résultat qui
est tout à fait anormal
je parle là du résultat du front
national qui est un jeu vétéran toutes
ces communes ce qui si jamais vu c'est
d'autant plus impressionnant comme
j'étais avec 34 liste et puis d'autre
part il ya le bon score et à le dire de
la france est soumise et surtout tendu
où son marché dont on connaît les
qualités qui avait débuté
sur temps et finalement les réunionnais
ont voulu le le reconduire parce qu'ils
s'estiment peu son travail était bien et
j'ai bien fait de ton c'est d'autant
plus que nous entraîne beaucoup au
parlement européen avec les options
marchi yannick jadot tête de liste pour
ces élections européennes expliqué
depuis ces élections que votre parti
n'était pas en position de force pour
recomposer la gauche met en position de
force pour recomposer le paysage
politique français
est ce que vous partagez cet avis cet
optimisme oui c'est que en position de
force est définitivement établi ça je ne
sais pas il est évident que la
centralité de la question écolo et
notamment que nous appelons de la
question climatique est la génération
climat qui depuis des mois et des mois
aujourd'hui fait l'actualité notamment
avec les mouvements qu'on sait après la
démission de nicolas hulot ou heures ans
pacsé partie de la 2de de gens qui font
pas de politique ont lancé un appel à
manifester pour le climat après
l'édition du loup et chose qui a pris
une grande importance puisque la mission
climat
initiée entre par le camarade marie tout
ça quand c'est une question centrale est
ce que l'on veut dire c'est que vous
êtes de gauche qui me reprochent à nous
et claude pas faire de différence entre
la droite et la gauche ne leur dis tout
simplement c'est vous qui va re
programme politique et parle édition
comprenait ne vous ici n'est pas de la
droite c'est pas nous c'est vous la
gauche productiviste ou ça vous
aujourd'hui à changer et à intégrer dans
votre logiciel centralité de la question
environnementale à ce que fera peut-être
avec les décisions de la khl de violence
y est surtout la question climatique et
je crois que là nous que nos partenaires
de la gauche traditionnelle ont beaucoup
de mal à intégrer ça on le voit dans
l'eau diction memmie ces réunions
gauche droite ça pour vous jean pierre a
tous un peu de sens plus de sens que ça
va encore je pense que les gens à gauche
qui sont sincères mais sur le plan du
rapport à l'opinion publique et
notamment la levée vous dire que des
commis par françois hollande elle est le
fameux discours du du bourget
si on faisait le catalogue des promesses
non tenues le temps des engagements pris
aux écolos on s'apercevrait
effectivement que beaucoup de gens ont
quitté entre kim et le champ d'à gauche
certains songent suivre pas se le cacher
pendant le vote pour marine le pen
d'autres dans l'abstention tout
simplement ça fait beaucoup de mal donc
aujourd'hui ce mot gauche
et on imaginer un peu mal perçu par ce
que le clivage les gens n'y croient plus
et notamment depuis le fait que c'est
quand même l'autre enseignement c'est
scrutin c'est l'effondrement non
seulement d'un socialiste est commencé
depuis deux ans et de l'autre grand
cadeau de la vie politique c'est le
républicain qui sont tombés 6 à 8%
enfin au plan national donc on a bien
quelque chose qui montre que le clivage
droite-gauche de parler chiffres que
l'on a des scouts électoraux et de par
là cette façon qu'on a deux pas le plus
en vue est installé à face à face entre
lui front national
et puis ce parti la plupart marche
devant qui dit qui n'est ni droite ni
gauche est emblématique
cet effondrement du clivage est la
structure la vie politique pendant plus
d'un siècle
aujourd'hui tout le monde est écolo on a
entendu pendant cette campagne
à part peut-être les républicains qui
ont assez peu justement fait leur
campagne là dessus tout les autres l'ont
fait le gouvernement aujourd'hui vous
dit edouard philippe dans son discours
de politique générale pour l'acte 2 on
va dire du du gouvernement dit parle
d'urgence écologique de c2c des
premières mesures qu'il a annoncées
étaient pour la fin du plastique est ce
que finalement vous idées n'ont pas déjà
gagnée infuser et réduisant du coup
l'intérêt de voter pour vous alors
qu'ils ont fusé oui mais là tirer pour
nous dresser puisque quand je vois les
décisions prises or par le premier
ministre je prends un simple exemple là
il évoque la fermeture centrale de
fessenheim
l'engagement de françois hollande qui
ont dû être cette centrale vieillotte
dangereuse rue de fermer fin 2016 elle
est ou pas fermé il nous la promet pour
avant 2020 je sais pas trop quoi il va
faire puisque c'est conditionné quand
même à la l'ouverture du fameux br le
réacteur à eau pressurisée de
flamanville qui n'est toujours pas
construit dont les coûts ont explosé
saviez pas le lait pourrait pourtant ce
qui les repoussent je prends du premie
des tons chauds de l'oci du gouvernement
de macron l'objectif de réduire la part
du nucléaire à 50%
c'était prévu pour 2016 c'est repoussé à
2035 dans ça ce sont des éléments
extrêmement fort et d'autre part les
annonces faites par l'office ne sont pas
financés non plus donc il faut
j'en serai tout risque comme le disait
je crois qu'une pis de l'âme du ministre
mais d'urgence et coulounieix pas
vraiment jusqu'où ils voient des gestes
forts et notamment ceux se ses taxes le
point dur de la politique énergétique
qui est le premier le faire pourquoi
parce que si on ne sort pas d'une
création donc on t'aime pas la sortie
qu'est ce qu'on fait eh bien on pénalise
les les énergies renouvelables parce que
tant qu'il ya du charbon de temps durera
du nucléaire on sait que c'est l'oubli
sont puissants on s'est fait un giroud
là on se rend la parole à la part
congrue 8 énergétique et on ne se
prépare pas à affronter la question
climatique
on va revenir dans un instant sur ces
questions de fond et notamment vu d'ici
à la réunion mais encore un peu de
politique politicienne dans le passé
souvent les leaders d'europe écologie
les verts ont fini par quitter le parti
se rapprocher du pouvoir en place ou des
partis majoritaires il ya une fuite
assez régulière de vos leaders vers le
pouvoir est ce que c'est parce que
finalement c'est pas mal d'être aux
manettes pour essayer de faire avancer
ses idées ou est-ce que c'est finalement
l'attrait du pouvoir qui qui fait fuiter
comme ça vaut leader alors je vais pas
jeter la pierre non plus sûr c'est que
le pouvoir corrompt
c'était pour le pouvoir corrompt et donc
ceux qui ont goûté les ordres et du lit
comme on dit on voulait conserver en
elle
la preuve avec notre ancien secrétaire
national emmanuel cause 5 qui nous
aident en plein cours de la rivière
il yad'autres qui effectivement que je
passe à pascal canfin ou pascal durand
de pascal canfin qui est parti chez
aulas qui sont pourtant dès la lakers
lourd bien ils ont préféré finalement
avoir rassuré dans ce gouvernement qui
pourtant giraud dix ans pour les textes
de pascal durand critique de la
politique énergétique menée par le
gouvernement
quand on a cru ont été muselés de
l'économie je vois pas comment il peut
être à l'aise aujourd'hui s'inscrit
fermement bon ça c'est un fait mais tous
les partis aujourd'hui de nombreuses
élus républicains qui tout à coup se
sentent plus proches je leur ai plus que
marre
tout simplement parce qu'ils veulent
être sûrs il va trés réélu donc la
rencontre où la question est posée de ce
genre sur éthique et politique l'éthique
en politique c'est de rester fidèle à
ses idées et c'est vrai que nous
- que nous avions choisi en vue cloud
jouer vers on a fait le choix de la
partie qui n'offrent pas de perspectives
glorieuses il faut se battre pendant des
années des années être finalisée il faut
rester fidèle à ses idées parce qu'un
jour ces idées finissent par devenir
majoritaire ensuite faut jamais oublier
le combat que nous avons mené pour ses
idées et je crois que ça encore ce qui
me concerne ça sable un petit peu la
conception de la politique on n'est pas
près de se vendre quoi que ce soit
hilali politique que l'europe écologie
va décliner je pense parler par les mois
à venir de dire aujourd'hui la question
centrale étant l'écologie elle n'est
plus là simplement la question de
répartition de richesses qui structurent
la vie politique la droite et la gauche
mais tout à l'heure elle est aujourd'hui
la question centrale c'est la question
qui va tic la question écologique la
question de transition énergétique
c'est celle là est donc l'enjeu que nous
avons nous l'europe écologie salam être
au centre du combat politique mais
pardon mais mais mais dans les alliances
j'allais dire politiques ou
politiciennes vous même jean pierre
marchau vous avez été avec paul vergès à
une époque pour pour la région
maintenant avec le gilbert annette qui
est très macro compatible à la mairie de
saint denis
vous êtes de ceux qu'ils considéraient
qu'il vaut mieux quand même être aux
manettes plutôt que dans l'opposition
alors il ya deux choses moi pendant
longtemps j'ai fait autrui syndicalisme
j'ai fait de l'association j'ai monté
une association sap taxi d'hommes qui a
lutté contre l'aspiration des déchets
les succès à l'époque puisqu'il avait
réussi à obliger quasiment tous les élus
a changé de fusil d'épaulé
c'était déjà en 2006 et voyez qu'on a
toujours évolué et puis je me suis rendu
compte ici que le social il ya quelque
chose il me manque le plan politique
parce que l'édition sens politique
quand j'ai décidé d'entrer effectivement
dans la majorité au plan municipal
internet
il ya eu un contrat a été signé sur la
fût leur lac et tous les points de
désaccord sur lesquels nous
maintiendrait nos désaccords
ça n'a pas changé quand j'ai des choses
à dire critique par rapport à général
est que ce soit en tant que mère où que
ce soit en tant que éminents socialistes
qu'on vous dit peut-être pas compatibles
je le dis j'ai déjà dit ici même et je
ferai toujours mais néanmoins et là je
m'adresse notamment à ces gens qui sont
le français écologiste
certains ont voté pour nous certains
n'ont pas voté parce qu'ils sont un peu
écoeurés par la politique
ils ont votera plus même si ils sont se
fera des écologistes je dis non
il faut enfin il faut entrer dans le
champ politique faut pas laisser la
politique aux politiciens professionnels
si vous faites effectivement ce qu'ils
vont prendre les décisions et les
mauvaises décisions
voilà je pense qu'il faut être capable
il faut se dire capable de mettre les
mains dans le cambouis
c'est difficile très difficile parce que
on est soudé d'état de pression mais si
on ne le fait pas on peut reste
effectivement pur et dur moi j'ai eu ma
période et coulon jeudi je prends 10 et
des projets retenus en intégration mais
ça suffit pas de dire non non non il est
pourquoi hélas le bruit suppose nous
oblige à dire pour qu'elle nous aussi de
ferney donc il faudra la politique on
construire cette alternative que je
viens d'évoquer
yannick jadot par le lors d'une
interview sur france inter il parlait de
dépasser europe ecologie les verts
vous allez avoir des instances des
réunions des débats dans les dents les
jours dans les semaines qui viennent
à quoi peut ressembler votre parti
demain ou après demain c'est le grand
débat parce qu'en fait semblant organisé
tout parti politique
surtout si devient vainqueur temps se
rigidifier sa vie risque à l'inter ce
parti allégeant les cadres qui ont envie
effectivement d'être élu et donc ils ont
donc enfin fonctionnement qui se
bureaucratise et ses noeuds il doit
sociologique miens au début d un du 6e
siècle produits localement mais
donc ce qu'on souhaite nous c'est sortir
cette façon de faire qui fait qu'un
parti est aussi fier rigidifier
lorsqu'on veut l'ouvrir sur la société
civile l'on prend en considération le
fait qu notamment la jeunesse n'a pas
envie d'entrer dans la boutique
politicienne qui vécurent un petit peu
donc pour en trouver la formule qui
permettent à des jeunes gens qui
aujourd'hui manifestent dans la rue
contre le climat faire chauffer
climatique ou d'autres les gens qui se
dit préfère fall associatif et qui ne
veut contraindre les petits bouchons
compte beaucoup dans le collectif des
carrières parce qu il ya des ce sont
environ mental et c'est en jouant à
cette méfiance par rapport au politique
et pourtant ces gens là une ingénierie
une connaissance des compétences que
nous devrions avoir au plan politique
donc comment est ce qu'on fait pour
aller me chercher alors qu'on fait c'est
là l'objet de quitter débat qu'on va
avoir un conseiller fédéral ce week-end
je serai que je me fais fayette
on a les journées d'été on a tout à
toulouse et surtout on a complètement
préparé pour novembre congrès national
j'essaie l'après conflit régional
pardon facile de construire cette force
ouverte ainsi des civils elle avait
essayé en 2010 avec l'écologie ça n'a
pas vraiment marché donc on a
l'expérience d'experts de ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire d'accord c'est à dire
faire un mouvement qui soit finalement
le mouvement un simple parti politique
je de leur transfert par ailleurs se
retrouve confronté au même problème
donc c'est à nous de le ménager pas la
réponse c'est ce qu'on va ici
inconscient collectivement que ce soit
d'autre que ce soit en ouvrant avec ce
nouveau c'est aux transformations mais
cela c'est là la clé certainement de la
sortie delà de ce face à face que l'on a
soit à droite soit entre l'ex droite et
la gauche
vous vous disiez les jeunes que vous
rencontrez éventuellement sur dans des
collectifs contre les carrières envoyé
dans un instant et est ce que on n'a pas
le sentiment que les jeunes se soient
vraiment mobilisé ici à la réunion les
marches qui sont là pour le climat ont
pas on pas ameuter quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de monde
pourquoi ce que
vous n'avez pas oublié alors qu'il -
demont fille qui manque en métropole
mois juste après le 15 mars il y avait
deux cent mille personnes la rue ici des
sons décembre en mars
des jeunes gens est notre toute jeune
femme qui sont pas politiques ont
organisé une marche aucun saint denis
c'est revenir à 800 900 personnes le
moment même c'est à paris pour ce qui
est pas mal pour la réunion
c'est vrai qu'on n'aime pas en décalage
et notre ya quinze jours il marcha
assagi l'ont été pour une centaine tout
à fait ce n'est que le début
on a un petit peu de retard après dessus
et l'essentiel c'est de laisser l'as et
ses groupes de citoyens s'organisent et
faut pas que le politique viennent
prendre là mais là dessus parce que ça
ça sera en travaux mais ce mouvement
mais c'est vrai que là peut-être parce
qu'on a un retard dans ses contrastes
sans titre conscientisation
je vois bien que le long du littoral où
finalement il n'y a pas une levée en
masse contre cette nouvelle route du
littoral cette levée ce fut un peu
tardivement par rapport aux carrières
tant mieux ça puisse se faire avant donc
il ya encore de beaucoup de travail le
chemin à faire notamment la réunion
tiens justement jean pierre marchau à
propos de de la nouvelle route du
littoral et des carrières il ya eu cet
avis défavorable sur l enquête publique
pour la carrière de bellevue certaines
certains j'imagine comme vous considérez
une victoire d'autres au contraire 10,1
là ça va encore retarder le chantier qui
doit se faire de toute façon il doit se
terminer ce chantier et ne pas ouvrir de
carrière savall retardé je souhaite que
le sentier de la victoire travailler le
plus possible et souhaite qu'il soit
abandonné le centre est claire à ce que
c'est possible de l'abandonner encore
oui c'est comme s'ils veulent abandonner
c'est toujours possible d'abandonner un
chantier parce que je vois pas l'intérêt
de le lancer alors qu'on sait qu'on
pourra pas le finir
ce à quoi on a du mal à finir car j'ai
eu du mal à finir sable la partie la
duke sur le l'avis défavorable de la
commission a pu glisser après faut que
je vois la vie aussi ferme jusqu'ici
elles avaient des avis plus ou moins
défavorable nous défendra donc avec des
réserves là c'est clairement défavorable
ce premier point et leur donne leur dû
hamstra tiff le favril qui a été clair
lui aussi la de sucre blanc le conseil
national de protection de la nature et
c'est très clair en décembre je pense
aujourd'hui que les rapports les gens
qui sont données montrent que cette
prétention de la dic serait non sens
donc que la région fini son viaduc et
qu'on trouve une issue fatale à tignes
comme face à une digue
non seulement parce qu'elle n'est pas la
construction mais parce que le fait de
la construire et on sera obligé de co2
est-ce que ricardo rocha civ est ce qu
ont une idée de combien ça coûterait
d'abandonner ce chantier alors là ces
régions qui vont avoir les chiffres mais
la région à l'époque se souvient il ya
34 ans ne fermait pas la porte à
construire une alternative à la dic et
finalement sous la pression du lobby de
france menteur à la privilégiées
indiquent sans s'apercevoir que l'entrée
dans une impasse et aujourd'hui on est
dans le dur
je rappelle qu'un autre tour 2011 11
environnementale qui des praticiens
d'écologie disais ok allez ma long du
littoral
ok mais aziz et c'est tout et prenez la
variante à tous à luc cardiaque a dit
que vous allez voir un problème qui a
surgi rapidement le progrès
provisionnement le problème de l'impact
environnemental et c'est exactement ce
qu'il se passait et qu'est ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui aux transporteurs qui ont
investi des millions pour acheter des
camions pour qui on voit la pensée
pouvoir gagner leur vie en travaillant
sur 7 sur sa construction de cette digue
on leur dit quoi aujourd'hui je rendais
aux camions je rappelle que les
transportant du même problème lorsqu'un
finnair ou des tamarins vous en souvenez
beaucoup sont retrouvés le bec dans
l'eau parce qu'une fois chantier fini
vous poussez très endettés pour acheter
des camions tout neuf et donc certains
ont été ruinées par ce qui s'est
endettée n'a pu rembourser leurs dettes
maintenant pour les transporteurs qui me
pensent qu'il faut il faut pas les
laisser à la rue si jamais effectivement
relance a dit moi je suis partisan et la
région de rangement l'important 2
de prendre en compte leur situation de
rencontrer transporter et de voir
comment on peut finalement soit les
aider à financer les achats ou
rembourser les dettes
et puis tous les aider à assurer la
transition puisqu'il ya des gens qui
travaillent
vers une nouvelle forme de chantier qui
deux des grands chantiers je crois sans
finir la réunion jesper fasth cultivées
en chantier donc mais ça c'est la région
a préparé un groupe de réflexion
intégrant les transporteurs pour les
aider dans la transition qui s'annonce
jean pierre marchau l'un des grands
chantiers dits et finalement à celui de
la route du littoral c'est celui des
transports de manière générale on a
l'impression que tout le monde dit on
est au bord du coma circulatoire la
voiture c'est plus possible il faut
absolument développer le transport en
commun ça fait des années et des années
qu'on entend ça et ça bouge pas beaucoup
ça bouge pas beaucoup
même si enfin depuis à ce qu'un peu plus
d'un an comme en voit qu'il ya des
projets et le projet ferroviaire le rail
conseil régional il ya le projet tramway
s'arrête un peu là dessus parce que on
rappellera que vous vous êtes vous
président de la commission transports à
la cinor il y a deux projets de tramway
pour la ville de saint denis entre
sainte marie saint denis en gros quoi
deux projets parallèles il est pas assez
embouteillée ailleurs pour que on est
deux projets même endroit et en 2009 il
y avait à ce projet comme a pu le
craindre un gala de danse à c'était pour
la petite remarque ironique
le bon sens voudrait effectivement que
le projet régional qui acceptera est en
fait un tronçon du rer tgv régionale 1
pouces qui serait qu'il transporte guy
des transports qui dès qu'ils seraient
vraiment qu'il fait le tour de l'île un
peu comme le projet de le faire je suis
passé par le boulevard sud passerait pas
le voir suite avec dix stations etc
donc on le connaît aujourd'hui il dira
en débat public actuellement le projet
du tramway est un président c'est pas un
tracé tram ou et lui passe pas il passe
à l'intérieur la vie sur lancers indices
s p
la dsp où je rappelle que vous utilisez
des sigles il faut s est produite
propre sur le bus qui passent qui prend
du champ centre ville vous avec les
rangs trois mille usagers sur ce ce
tronçon là et que si on ne fait rien eh
bien on leur être ou pour l'asphyxier on
sait que ce transport en site propre
acculés aujourd'hui de retard d'autant
plus qu'ils ont c'est la question de
l'aéroport donc sinon a choisi de
l'ancien tramway qui réduit de
l'aéroport à prendre une partie du sud
conjointement à grenaille ensuite
prendre et là le acceptable si c'est
pour aller dans un centre ville dans un
projet urbain interurbain l'objet des
intervenants mais l'idéal c'est ce que
nous il est avec la commission nationale
n'ait pas pu les we qui vous demandent
quand même de nous concerter un minimum
quoi alors on se concertera en contenant
sa c4 est dans son coin mais néanmoins
l'état pousse effectivement à la
convergence la canche dans des projets
dont moi je pense le bon sens voudrait
que l'on arrive à se mettre autour d'une
table et de voir si on peut faire
converger de pour les deux projets ou
alors et priorisées dans le temps c'est
à dire en réaliser un emploi parce que
l'état pourra pas financer les deux mois
j'étais à peu près - roux au stif à
paris où l'agencé de financement des
infrastructures de ce côté régional donc
été là et on lui pose la question je
t'ai charles le maillot puisque cela
sinon elle à présent sinon pour le
financement du fameux tramway et le
serait original dont l apport du
financement des infrastructures
ferroviaires et disait a par la suite de
l'album la loi d'orientation de la
mobilité
il y aurait de dotation globale mais il
faudrait pas que chaque projet
ferroviaire qui rend france ne pourra
pas recevoir dix étaient plus de 40
millions de l'état
je rappelle qu'en 2009 le train régional
tram-train 8 et financières à plus de
400 millions
donc on a changé d'échelle et il faut
savoir donc la pénurie financière ou la
la réticence de l'état entrer là-dedans
montrent qu'on peut pas faire 36 projets
ferroviaires parce qu'il faut aussi
parler de projet fera du tc automobile
je pense qu'on aura des rencontres entre
les présidents de six noms de la région
pour voir comment faire soient
priorisées dans le temps soit arrive à
faire converger les converger quelque
chose qui n'est pas la même chose
c'est compliqué parce qu'un train
ce n'est pas la même chose on a le
sentiment qu'ils manquent
une vision globale du transport en
commun à la réunion est-ce que c'est
plutôt à la région de gérer ça est-ce
que ça serait ce syndicat mixte des
transports qui est en train de voler en
éclats on sait que le son président alex
cas le bois est mis en minorité qui
pourrait éventuellement démissionner
c'était dans les colonnes de nos
confrères du quotidien
voilà je vous sentez venir sur la
question effectivement je suis vraiment
moi je suis mon sens quasi dans le cinq
amis des transports et je cache pas
puisque j'ai dit publiquement depuis
deux ans je vous le dis je le dise quoi
le bois qui sont comtoise je lui ai dit
écoute alice il n'a plus la confiance
des vice-présidents sur les votes
importants il se retrouve tout seul même
si le représentant de sa propre
collectivité à 602 contre lui tout le
monde votre contre lui il s'accroche au
pouvoir
si l'âge il faut qu'il passe la main je
dis depuis deux ans se syndicaliser
transport qui pour être servi roanne
puis c'est une coordination une vision
globale qu'on vous dit il ne fait rien
donc là aujourd'hui je sais que c'est
dans la presse michel fontaine veut le
rencontrer
je pense qu'il faut que l ifrap rachète
l'eponge qu'on puisse rapidement nommer
un nouveau une nouvelle présidente pour
remettre en selle ce samedi même s'il
est sauvé le président de ça pour être
le retour de fabienne couapel-sauret
forcément que j'étais candidat en
laissant et je compte bien effectivement
puisque je suis cette affaire de très
près faire valoir aussi les des éléments
qui sont propres à la cinor dans ce
dossier là donc on verra c'est pas il
fallait il m'a dit qu'il n'était pas
candidat toute façon mais quel que soit
le vous vous serez candidat il faut ces
[Musique]
progrès condition c'est que alice les
vicieux en puissance
une nouvelle équipe que la confiance
revienne on commence à travailler non
pas sur l'hérault dossier parce qu'on
s'est fendu en 2020 il renouvellement
des collectivités des mairies dont
certains mais nouvelle équipe
ça veut dire qu'on est piégé encore par
un calendrier électoral il faut attendre
encore 2021 pour commencer
fin août aussi con pas été traités je
pense que le s'interpose se saisir des
cons projets portés ils ne voient un peu
la voie du consensus est en cours à
faire même si le temps aujourd'hui ça
s'est rapidement
et puis il y aura certainement mettre en
place un nouveau style nouvelle
billettique pas là même qui était portée
par le président parce que c'est ça qui
a posé problème à parfaire le 6 mai
c'était ça c'est un projet de
billetterie unique qui dit je suis trop
onéreux voilà bien faire comprendre aux
gens c'est les réseaux de transport sans
développer chacun et de mères isolées à
celui de 6 selon lui la civis et serra 6
à s'habiller que lourdes les autres en
et billettique légère mais en fait il
faut que tout ça quoi s'il c'est absurde
parce que le visage et lui qui prend son
bus à saint denis qui va à saint pierre
il raisonne pas comme le politique
il s'est passé un bus du réseau citalis
tout laissait donc il faut aujourd'hui
qu'on sorte de cette c'est seulement
qu'on fait la vraie coordination échos
mettent en place une carte bus qui soit
valable sur tous les réseaux avec un
tarif harmonisé dans les lois encore
hélas le saint père devrait jouer un
rôle
ces transports donc il ne l'a pas joué
vraiment j'espère que dans quelques
jours il pourra mettre en place un
gouvernement hivernants ce qui prendra
corps le problème quand on parle du
syndicat mixte des transports
assez rapidement on parle aussi des
intérêts privés qui sont sous-jacents et
qui sont parfois pointés du doigt et
notamment la transdev qui est cette
entreprise qui a finalement débit un peu
partout et qui donc a un poids financier
important et qui pourrait aussi influer
sur les décisions politiques comme je le
dis c'est tous ces transports sont
construits au fil des ans chacun sur les
territoires séparés avec les
collectivités haddock la cirest c'est
aussi cet été mais avec des acteurs
privés qui sont vraiment mieux qui sont
les grands les grands de la chine et du
transport après chaque collectivité
puisque pour l'instant quelques
irresponsables 73 préfèrent jouer la
concurrence elle est évident que la
concurrence peut venir que s'appelle
keolis telle ou telle filière allo ici
et c'est alors pour marcher du centre
n'a parlé moi j'ai rien contre ici ce
sont des grands professionnels sur la
façon dont le projet était porté par les
paysans qui sont cools extravagant
exactement jusqu'en 2030
voilà donc maintenant qu'il est privé
ont un rôle à jouer là est ce que le
rôle de cimenter co2 les transporteurs
je vous prends petit laissé des traces
preneur je crois pas si la sphère des
professionnels il faut que ces
professionnels se professionnaliser
encore beaucoup de transporteurs privés
donc il ya une en un travail à faire
quand je suis bien d'accord qu'il faut
éviter l'hégémonie de tel ou tel groupe
ou sur tel ou tel réseau pour l'instant
est ce que cette hégémonie 7,7 puissance
de la transdev pose un problème
or ce qui concerne le cmtr absolument
pas le transport sauf si la voiture
électrique on n'avance pas non plus trop
sûr sur ce dossier avec la difficulté
que pour l'instant pour faire rouler de
l'électrique il faut faire fonctionner
des centrales au fioul et au charbon en
termes de transition écologique c'est
pas gagné oui c'est un discours depuis
très longtemps en fait - europe écologie
c'est à dire que la voiture électrique
n'est pas la panacée est pas la panacée
encore moins la réunion là où les
positions elle est restée fortement
carbonées et on a fait les calculs si
aujourd'hui nous voitures et les
voitures du graitery qui ce qui roule
aujourd'hui à la réunion sont plus
polluantes par le fait que l'exercice et
vient du charbon qu'une voiture
thermique
donc c'est pas la panacée et avant deux
là se lancer dans le bus qui la patience
vis à vis aussi que demain peut-être
avec des aides ils pourront lancer des
véhicules électriques
c'est surtout devenir le 10 mai la place
de la voiture individuelle qu'ils soient
thermique ou électrique il faire place à
des transports en commun moderne
régulier sécurisé où on a du plaisir à
prendre comme vous voulez dans les
grandes villes d'un graal métropole un
transport en commun pour déplacer aller
travailler ou aller au stade où aller
aux cimes
est ce que on a parlé tout à l'heure des
mesures annoncées par le gouvernement
sur le plastique ici j'imagine que en
suisse a aussi europe ecologie les verts
de près est ce qu'on peut imaginer que
la réunion se passe de plastique
rapidement oui rapidement après il faut
vous donner un échéancier mais c'est
vrai que c'est une question cruciale sur
une île puisqu'on sait que le plastique
on le retrouve aujourd'hui dans le
ventre des mêmes et des boeufs et marins
des poissons et herat
donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on constate de
tous et que ce sont surtout des citoyens
qui font des actions de ramassage
déplacer sur les plages donc c'est ce
que c'était à eux de faire ils le font
parce que les autos qui publics n'ont
pas été finalement assez ferme sur une
tradition du plastique et ses annexes
importants que ce soit les réunions en
métropole le ce clasico nous avons été
vendus pendant les années 50 ou 60 qu'on
n'a pas assez aujourd'hui s'avère
extrêmement destructeur de notre
environnement
ce qui est vrai c'était une
conscientisation aujourd'hui de tous
donc nous devons faire demain le
contraire de ce que nous avons fait hier
c'est à dire choisir des matériaux pour
demain qui soit éco-compatible et non
pas des matériaux qui sont destructeur
pour l'environnement
les prochaines échéances électorales
commence à se préparer on imagine vous
avez dit vous avez un certain nombre de
réunions au niveau national de combat
etc
il n'empêche que les municipales
approchent dans mars
c'est bientôt oui est-ce que vous avez
déjà une position à ce que vous irez
dans toutes les communes avec des
candidats est ce que vous ferez des
alliances au premier et au deuxième tour
la ligne que nous avons écologie et à la
réunion notamment c'était qu'il ya des
types d'élections ou vu l'état des
forces pour nous de présenter dix tomes
il y en a d'autres au contraire
systématiquement ne sont autonomes de
temps en france où l'initiative
je pense que nous avons vocation savoie
initiative ou départementales avoir des
candidats europe écologie est pas avoir
d à court de partie on dire en se
faisant pas là on vous laisse pas passer
ça marchera pas ça marche plus et ça
marchera pas et on veut pas le faire
par contre on est ici plus compliqué à
la réunion au national on sait qu'il ya
d'excellents résultats qui ont été faits
par hope écologie à nantes à strasbourg
à grenoble déjà une vie les couloirs à
paris dans certains quartiers de l'est
parisien
donc il y aura des listes europe
écologie très ouverte
effectivement il y aurait de cadrage
national qui sera votée certainement ce
week-end pour dire en gros comment on va
faire mais ce que nous souhaitons et
vient maintenant la réunion
donc il ya des discussions qui sont
engagés de voir là au cas par cas
comment est ce que l'on va faire mais la
consigne c'est quand même de porter haut
le drapeau d'écologie mais être la
question d'être cogis centrale dans un
programme ici parce que même à l'échelle
de la commune y ait de la transition
énergétique
il a des mesures que l'on doit prendre
que l'on peut prendre une énergie le
clip ou décliner les plans climat
énergie delà des collectivités au plan
communal
la question des déchets donc c'est une
question centrale
il y aura des discussions et
moi ce que je fais donc concerne ali
s'est construit une plateforme assez
ouverte sur la question et couleau on
voit ensuite des négociations demain
avec les forces politiques qui
s'engageront mais où en france en avant
l'écologie c'est tout c'est un peu
langue de bois
concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que vous vous êtes en train de
réfléchir aux conditions d'une nouvelle
alliance avec avec gilbert annette dès
le premier tour des conditionnels
alliance à saint denis et saint paul
nous avons déjà des élus de telles
alliances s'animer la majorité simple
opposition donc qu'il y à il y aura des
discussions mais qui sont pas pressés
pour le faire il ya ce qui aura lieu au
sein de l'application programmatique
on attend effectivement de ne mettre au
coeur des programmes parce que jacques
momha fergie dans ces années écoulées
que je prends je pense à neuilly en
faire un bilan
qu'est-ce qui a été qu'est ce qui n'a
pas été il ya des choses qui sont allés
ça c'est clair dont va se rencontrer
mettre ça sur la table et on veut une
impulsion pour changer cette ville qui
changerait pas suffisamment en cours sur
certains points donc il y aura des
discussions
voilà pour d'autres je rencontre aussi
les sur un parti socialiste mais
maintenant poser soumis le parti
communiste s'est donc il y aura des
discussions parce qu'il ya des villes où
nous ça reste à gauche malgré tout voilà
ça reste à gauche mais interdit de
rencontrer des gens qui sont qui n'ont
pas d'étiquette politique
j'ai rencontré jambes n'ont pas
d'étiquette politique qui ont peut-être
une sensiblité plutôt centriste
donc on a des discussions qui sont
ouvertes avec eux et voilà ce qu'il nous
faut c'est voir comment on se construit
c'est une alliance pour pouvoir si
important soir les élus écolos de masse
j'espère m'imposer association nos
gentils sont qui s'intéressent à la
politique qui ont les compétences ne
restez pas sur le bon chemin
vous venez vous avez des formes et quand
on est élu on se forme on a la maîtrise
des dossiers et on peut faire entendre
une voix qu'elle est lui qui n'a pas de
compétences particulières peut ne pas
avoir ou ne pas faire entendre parce
qu'ils ne voient pas la problématique
il ya des
des gens qui ont été finalement
entraînée par la dynamique actuelle et
qui sont venus vous voir adhérer ou est
ce que vous êtes en manque de et
d'adhérents et de militants il ya
effectivement des gens depuis 22.65 il
adhère alors souvent il a directement
sur le site national par carte bleue
donc un prix nous c'est moral est
repérée elle prend des contacts et voilà
il ya des gens effectivement un drop qui
veulent revenir donc ils vont en train
de discuter pour voir et puis de faire
en sorte surtout il ya vingt-quatre
communes ce que je souhaite c'est
passion pour remplir ce programme là
c'est qu'on ait des élus présents dans
les listes qui mettront dans leur
programme l'écologie parce que l'idéal
effectivement quand je vous le disais
c'est qu'on ait des élus qui sont en
responsabilité sur les questions
énergétiques telles qu'elles sont la
mobilité parce que c'est ça qui forme
parce que vous les avez ces militants
c'est ses futurs candidats pour les
opposants vous fait renaître pour toutes
les collectes pour tout découvrir
après tout si non quelles communes où on
lisait pas encore on sait pas si on les
aura on verra là juste en train de faire
le tour justement depuis depuis dizaine
de jours de jean-paul beaucoup de monde
et puis à des gens qui veulent bien
intérêts qu'il veut peut-être pas non
plus franchir le pas de la politique
parce que oui ticket est peut-être mal
vu donc il faut convaincre les gens que
si j'aime pas de danse et qu'ils vont
laisser la place à d'autres qui monte
pas l'intérêt qu'ils ont pour
l'environnement l'écologie et la
transition énergétique
alors justement la crise démocratique
qui était convoité chaque élection par
le taux d'abstention record qu'on voit
qu'on a vu aussi par la crise des gilet
jaune qu'on voit peut-être d'une
certaine manière par le ceux qui
revendiquent un vote de protestation
quand ils vont voter pour le
rassemblement national
cette crise là comment est-ce que
comment est ce que vous pouvez
comment est ce que vous pouvez faire
avec comment est ce que vous pouvez
continuer à exister dans une telle
défiance du politique je pense que si un
parti ou un mouvement politique je sais
pas si on peut encore être les partis
qui à sa place
mais si vous me permettez redonner un
peu d une explication rapide de la crise
actuelle et ça vaut aussi pour les gilet
jaune
c'est dire que la réalité commencé en
tant qu'unité quand le travail dans
l'acte de production du travail se met
en place des relations
social rapports sociaux il rate chizé
depuis l'antiquité jusqu'à nos jours
le rapport de l' esclavage les rapports
du servage pendant longtemps la source
de l'énergie s'était pas eu un
et puis quand la à trouver sent bon la
machine à la peur et puis on a libéré
trahi main le travail souvent sur le
marché aujourd'hui et on l'a vécu sur la
l'idée de l'abondance des ressources
énergétiques de charbon et le pétrole
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que ces
ressources se raréfient et donc
l'énergie
elle se vérifiait devient de plus en
plus cher et donc les sociétés
d'abondance qui s'est construite depuis
notamment la deuxième guerre mondiale
elle commence aujourd'hui à ne plus
ressembler ne se rendra pas certainement
à ce qu'elle était dans les années 50
parce que si cette énergie sera rifi
devient et c'est ça la crise et gilet
jaune
les premiers confrontés à la crise
énergétique sont les gens qui utilisent
en plus combien transport parce qu'il
est en réalité loin des villes lorsque
le prix du terrain dans les
centre-villes devient de plus en plus
cher donc c'est un peu les ou lisent
cette histoire et cette crise l epa il
faut pas l'analyse et à avec la lumière
de révolution française d'une révolution
de 1830 on sait pas une crise
aujourd'hui de civilisation qui peut
plus développés parce que la question
énergétique et de questions cruciales et
les premiers touchés sont les pauvres
deuxième les classe moyenne qui habitent
loin des villes et ça va aujourd'hui de
plus en plus affecté les gens donc si on
ne change pas de façon de se développer
de l'année le territoire sur le fût pas
venir on ira jeu radical dans les dix
prochaines années qu'est ce qui va se
passer
eh bien on risque de cali sous la
contrainte dans 10 ou 15 ans parce que
effectivement quand la la la grave crise
jeunes on attend seul oublié mais on
meurt décembre on était au bord de la
révolution une véritable révolte de gens
qui supportait pas d'être la victime de
cette crise vient d'évoquer surtout en
précision sans l'instant de
considération dont l'enjeu est là il est
de
affronter cette crise de la civilisation
qui est donc une crise aussi du rap au
politique
les gens ont envie de s'exprimer d'où le
fait et c'est ce que je crois dit si
vous voulez vous exprimer
il faudra qu'on peut pas rester en dhr
la politique être citoyen c'est être un
jeune qui fait la politique ce
qu'aristote donc il faut retrouver
l'esprit civique des grecs et l'entrée
dans le champ politique ne pas le
laisser aller les gens qui ne sont pas
des qui sont munis pour mu en des
considérations qui sont pas forcément ça
le dire l'intérêt général merci jean
pierre marchau d'avoir été avec nous de
réflexion philosophique à poursuivre
vous confirmez vous serez candidat à la
présidence du cmtr et vous serez
probablement candidat sur une liste
quelque part aux prochaines municipales
à saint denis a de fortes chances
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
dans un moment ses musiques et passer
une excellente journée sur la première
tu
[Musique]
m